April wrote in saying is it a bad idea
to loan people money you know it's not a
bad idea for banks to do it I'm going to
assume that the question April is asking
is whether it's a bad idea as an
individual to make personal loans to
other people I generally think it's not
a great idea and I one time did and I'm
not talking about here's hey here's 10
bucks because you forgot your wallet to
get yourself you know a beer I'm talking
about loaning some amount of money where
a friend comes to you and says hey could
I borrow some amount of money that is
not insignificant I do think it's a
pretty bad idea and once I stupidly
student not because I didn't get paid
back but because I didn't like the
dynamic it created a friend of mine
needed some money I think it was like
when I was in college and I worked when
I was in college so I actually had some
money which not everybody did and a
friend needed money to pay off like
credit card debt or something like that
and I loaned them loan them the money
and we came up with you know some
interest rate and whatever and he paid
it back and everything was totally fine
but I just didn't like the dynamic of it
and I regret having done it and if he
hadn't paid it back it definitely would
have created some problems see that's
interesting so he paid you interest but
you insisted on it okay interesting
because usually when friends lend each
other money that's not even something
that gets brought up though the person
that lends out the money is just taking
all the risk they can't win in any
anyway I mean it's going to create this
awkward dynamic right and the best-case
scenario is that you just get the money
back that you started with and I've and
basically what happened was I said you
know I can let you borrow the money when
do you think you can pay me back and he
said well I'll pay whatever the schedule
was that he figured out he said he was
going to make me an extra payment which
was going to be sort of like the
interest or whatever and I think that
even made it more awkward I think the
best thing is if you can afford to just
give a friend money for whatever they
need with no expectation that you'll be
paid back that's the best way to go
about it and if they independently say
hey you know what I really appreciate
when you gave me that money six months
ago or a year ago or whatever here's the
money back that's the best way to go
with no expectation that this is money
that's going to be paid back and if you
can't
afford to just give someone money I
think it's got to be okay to say you
know what that's not that's not
something that I can afford right I mean
that would be incredibly generous I mean
you have to see it as a warning side to
that he's not able to make his credit
card payments if somebody needs money in
order to pay off a debt they've already
closed to defaulted on maybe you're not
the best person to be then loaning
further money but yeah I'm basically
against doing this the only exception
would be there are sometimes you know
there are people who do real estate
flips and they will write up a contract
like it's still a legal contract but
instead of getting a mortgage because
they want to flip it quickly they'll
have a group of people they know maybe
personally and they'll go to them to
finance like the cash purchase of a
clearly I've never done this as you can
tell the cash purchase of a house that's
being auctioned by the bank a
repossessed house or whatever a
foreclosure and then you write up some
contract and then the idea is we fix it
and flip it within three months and then
you get your money back plus some
interest but even then I think like if
you're talking about a friends
relationship it's pretty damn risky to
do that right and it obviously just
complicates things when you have to get
your money back and maybe lending to
family is something I would consider a
little bit more because I would
understand even if I don't get the
return it's going to help my immediate
family member but that's why I think
you're better off saying it's not a loan
listen I'm going to help you out by
giving you this money if you can afford
it and then if at some point you can pay
me back then you'll pay me back but
still thinking about it that way you
know it's not a pleasant situation now
certainly not to ask for the money not
to lend it out either definitely all
right that's my thought there